Five years ago, I
decided to learn more
about two exciting frameworks
that I kept hearing about more
and more often everywhere,
really, in bars, restaurants.
It got really spooky.
The first is the R tidyverse
from Hadley's and Garrett's
great book, R for Data Science.
And some of you might
have heard of it, maybe.
And the second one is the
Kaggle machine learning and data
science platform.
And little did I
know at the time
that the combination
of those frameworks
would transform my
career and open up
a whole new world of
exciting challenges.
And much like for our
dragonball friends there.
This fusion really
boosted my power level.
So today I would
like to show you
how the community can help
you to grow, to learn,
and to inspire others.
And whether you're
a regular on Kaggle,
you've only ever dipped your
toes into the community,
or you've never
heard of it at all,
I hope that my talk
and my story will
inspire you to make the most
out of the amazing opportunities
that the Kaggle
community provides,
and that in turn, you will
then share your great ideas
and creativity with
the rest of us.
"Now that sounds
great," you might say.
"I have a very small
question, though.
What is Kaggle?"
Well, I'm glad you asked.
Kaggle.com was
launched 13 years ago
as a website for machine
learning competitions.
And that means that
the goal is to build
competitive predictive models
on a specific machine learning
problem with the best
models in the end,
scoring highest on an
objective leaderboard.
And while competitions remain
one of the main cornerstones
today, Kaggle covers
many key aspects
of the data science landscape.
Users can upload and
curate their own data sets.
Lively discussion forums
host many conversations
about machine learning
and data science,
and kagglers can build, run,
and publish their own notebooks
directly on the site.
And there's so much to learn
here, so much to discover.
But I also realize that all
these possibilities can be
a little bit confusing, right?
Maybe intimidating when you're
joining the site at first,
and I get it.
I really do.
When I joined Kaggle back in
the day, I felt the same.
I felt a little
bit hesitant when
I saw all these smart people
and their clever ideas.
So much so, in
fact, that I decided
to join up anonymously under
the pseudonym heads or tails.
Nobody knew who I really was.
And that helped alleviate
much of the pressure
that I would have
otherwise put myself
under when it comes to actively
participating in the community.
So with this little
trick, I felt
free to work my regular
job during the day
and be on Kaggle in my secret
identity in the evenings
and well, nights.
But what I quickly realized is
that much like the R community,
the Kaggle community
was exceptionally
welcoming and supportive
of its new members.
And it remains so to this day.
The other trick that helped
me was at first to only
focus on one aspect of
Kaggle rather than trying
to do everything at once.
And in my case, I gravitated
towards the notebooks.
You see, I'm a
very visual person,
and my academic
background had trained
me to write coherent reports.
And my goal on
Kaggle was to learn
new tools and new methods.
And I always learn best when
I can apply these new tools
on a practical problem.
So it came natural to me to
start writing and publishing
notebooks to learn and to share
what I learned with others.
And so today my talk will be
revolving around the notebooks.
But much of what
I'm telling you can
be translated to
other aspects as well,
like discussions or
competitions, or also
courses which might be
more relevant for you
and your goals.
And all these aspects
are representative
of Kaggle as a whole,
and in turn they
also contain smaller areas that
are representative of them.
So in a sense, much
like a cauliflower,
this is a fractal approach
and a fractal talk
in which I would
like to show you
that I can be less than just
a one dimensional speaker.
I'd take that.
So I started learning
the tidyverse
and to write notebooks, to
practice what I had learned.
And I also started
reading the notebooks
that other people
were putting out.
And that really
exploded my horizons.
There was so much creativity,
so many great ideas out there.
To give you an example.
I remember when I
first discovered
this notebook written by
Jonathan in R on US flight
tracking data.
And I had never worked with
geospatial data before.
And his map visuals, they
just blew my mind. The way
that he presented his
insights was so clean
and well thought out.
There's a lot going
on in this map
that the different
cities, the flight routes,
but the design choices
make this visual
very clear and accessible.
So I wanted to learn
about geospatial data.
And then this
competition launched,
which was about predicting
taxi trip durations in New York
city, but it was really
about writing notebooks
that other people would find
useful, exploring the data,
breaking it down, finding
all the hidden insights.
So I took my
exploratory approach
and I started to
learn from scratch
about maps and geocoordinates
and all these things.
And this is my very
first interactive leaflet
map that I built for this
notebook that I wrote,
and I'm still
using leaflet today
based on what I learned
from this experience.
It's a great tool.
And even better, my
notebook ended up
receiving the most community
votes in this competition
and winning me a prize.
I was awesome.
I mean, I was over the moon.
[applause] Oh, Thank you.
Thank you.
Yeah and I had found
my new passion.
So over the following
months, I jumped
into almost every new
competition that was launched.
So that I could learn
about the specific tools
that were needed to
understand the data.
And my goal was to
be the first person
to write a comprehensive
exploratory data analysis
for the competition data.
So that when new people
joined the competition,
they could get a jumpstart.
So EDA became my
focus and it allowed
me to discover and to
share lots of cool stuff.
So for instance, I joined a time
series forecasting competition
to learn about methods like
ARIMA or tools like Prophet.
And this particular example
was about predicting web views
for specific international
Wikipedia pages.
So here in this
example plot, you
see that the views for the wiki
page of the band Twenty One Pilots
exploded dramatically
in early 2016.
I don't really know them.
I don't know why that happened.
But there are some
interesting lag effects here
as to how this rise happened
in the different countries that
are coded by different colors
and in some interesting lags
in the spikes too, that pop up.
So features like this
made this competition
interesting and challenging.
And I also joined my
first NLP competitions,
learning how to use Julia's
and David's great tidytext
package.
And in this particular one I was
flexing my storytelling muscles
and I wrote my own
chilling short story
around the analysis of language
used by classic horror writers
like Shelley or Lovecraft.
Right? so you see
that love and death
are there at the center
of most of these stories,
intertwined in an
eternal battle.
And with every new notebook
and every new competition,
I was learning something new.
New tools, new tricks,
and new ideas from reading
other people's notebooks
and exchanging
thoughts with them.
You see, one of the great
things about Kaggle notebooks
is that you can
fork and tweak them
directly on the website using
this little button up there.
And you see this often with
competition modeling code,
and people build on
each other's models
and make them
better step by step.
The Kaggle community is
very good at learning
from each other,
and it's standing
on each other's shoulders to
see further than we otherwise
could.
And myself,
I owe a lot to the support
of the Kaggle community,
which made me the very first
notebook's grandmaster, which
is a title that you can
earn through community
votes on your
notebooks, and then
you can take your
achievements and your work
and you can showcase
it to the world
through your Kaggle profile,
for instance, to recruiters.
So this is my profile,
which kind of summarizes
my top notebooks
and data sets and so
on in a very comprehensive way.
And I'm pretty positive
that it helped me
a lot in my transition from
the ivory towers of academia
to doing data science
in the real world.
And a lot of the
interviews that I
had with various
companies, the lessons
that I had learned on
Kaggle, they were invaluable.
And I'm sure the
whole grandmaster
thing didn't hurt either.
Right, it's like.
But, Yeah.
So I believe that the use
of Kaggle as a portfolio
remains very
underrated even today.
It's a great way to
showcase your work,
especially in notebooks.
And I would really like
to encourage you to make
your Kaggle notebooks public.
I've read a lot of notebooks
over the last five years,
and virtually all of them
had something interesting
that I could learn, and
I felt very grateful
towards the authors.
In fact, two years ago, I
decided to start an initiative
around the Kaggle notebooks.
So let me tell you
about my initiative.
Oh, no, no, not that one.
No, no, no.
That's not the one either.
Oh, man.
I'm dating myself with
that reference, right?
It's been a while.
No, what I'm talking
about is an initiative
to discover and highlight
great Kaggle notebooks, which,
for whatever reason,
haven't gotten
the attention and kudos from
the community that they deserve.
I'm calling them hidden gems,
and after reading hundreds
of notebooks and writing
quite a few myself,
I would like to share with you
what Kaggle taught me on how
to write a great notebook.
So here are a few tips
that will be illustrated
by different hidden gems.
So first of all, you want
to introduce your work
to capture your
reader's attention
and draw them into
your analysis.
A couple of topical
images or illustrations
go always well with a
few opening paragraphs
that explain the
goals, the context,
and set the scene
for what's to follow.
So like Laura here, you could
use an image of cocoa beans
to lead into your flavorful
analysis of chocolate taste
ratings.
Explaining your methodology
will help your reader
to follow your analysis
through its various steps.
And this can be part
of your introduction,
and you can even go
as far as Ramshankar did
and build a flowchart out
of little pictograms that
explain the different
steps of your analysis.
And this is really some next
level methodology communication
right there.
Great visuals,
of course, they are
they are at the heart of
many fantastic notebooks.
And whether it's for exploration
or for communication,
you want your data
visualizations
to be clear and accessible
in communicating the insights
that you derived.
And that can mean
simple visuals,
but it can also mean
complex but well designed.
So in this example here,
Daniel was creating a visual
for climate models and rising
CO2 levels that would not
look out of place in
a science or nature
paper on some high
profile website.
Right? it's
meticulously designed
with insets and
annotations and definitely
takes a little time to digest.
So like with all of them,
if you want to learn more,
definitely check
out the notebook.
But visuals themselves
are not enough, right?
You also want to
document your findings
and what you read
in those visuals,
not just for your audience,
but also for yourself.
So that if you come
back to your notebook
maybe six months later,
you will thank past you
for writing down what was so
interesting about these plots
that you made.
Right, and Parul here
demonstrates this very well
with her points
to note, complete
with a little pictogram
as a visual anchor.
And documentation is, of
course, the cousin of narration.
So you always want to
have a nice narrative
flow that leads your reader
through your analysis from one
step to another.
As my final tip,
for today, at least,
you can take your
visualizations and exploration
from the exploration of data
to the explanation of models.
And one of the most
outstanding hidden gems,
Jack here was charting
the journey of an image
through a neural network.
Which is a fantastic
title, by the way.
Titles are important, too,
but what I wanted to focus on
is the way in which he uses
the data visualizations
to show how this handwritten
digit gets transformed
through the different
layers of the neural network
all the way down to the
classification layer.
And what happens in between.
All right.
So if you want to learn
more about deep learning
or if you just want to
read something really cool,
check out Jack's notebook.
It's great.
So some of you
might have noticed
that all of these examples that
I showed you for hidden gems
were from Python notebooks.
As a bit of a contrast
to the earlier R
notebooks that I showed.
And today, Python is definitely
the most popular language
on Kaggle, especially for
deep learning applications.
But there's still plenty
of great R content
around. In 300 hidden gems
that are collected so far,
I found that the ratio was 3/4
of the notebooks were in Python
and 1/4 in R, and
it shouldn't stop you
if a notebook is
in Python, right,
you can still learn
a lot from it.
In fact, one neat
way of learning
might be to take the ideas
from a Python notebook
and translate them into
R, right, or vice versa.
That might be a good way for
you to get started on Kaggle,
but for the closing
thought of this talk,
I might have an even
better way for you
to start your own
Kaggle journey.
Because I've put
together a Kaggle dataset
specifically
for this conference,
and it contains the
names of all the packages
that are currently
on CRAN together
with quite a bit
of their metadata
and all their release history.
So there are quite a
few features in there
that could be
interesting for R users
and you could start digging
into these features directly
on the website by pressing
this button there,
which will create a new notebook
that will get you to an editor
and you can start analyzing
the data right there
on the website.
So I would like to invite you
to go to the data set page,
for instance, by
scanning this handy QR
code that's there in the corner.
Open up a new notebook and start
your very own Kaggle journey
right here, right today.
And I will be looking
forward to see
all the great ideas
and creativity
that you will bring in.
I would love to welcome all of
you to the Kaggle community.
And right now, I
welcome your questions.
Thank you.